FEMALE SPEAKER: Great.
So welcome everybody,
and thank you
for coming along to today's
Authors at Google Talk.
I'm incredibly excited to
welcome Doug Stevenson.
He's going to be talking to us
today about the power of story.
Doug has had a 20-year acting
career, of which 13 years was
spent in Hollywood, acting in
everything in movies ranging
from "Snoopy" all the way
through to Shakespeare.
In your first movie,
I believe that you
were responsible for karate
chopping Chuck Norris.
DOUG STEVENSON: No,
actually it was the reverse.
I was karate chopped
by Chuck Norris.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Oh,
OK, there you go.
And in your most
recent movie, it
was a Perry Mason
movie, isn't that right?
DOUG STEVENSON: Yes, yes, yes.
Perry Mason movie of the week.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Great.
And so we're excited
to be spending time.
We need to learn a little
bit more about storytelling
and the power of storytelling
and the content that's
in your book, "The
Story Theater Method."
So over to you.
DOUG STEVENSON: Thank you.
Thank you.
It's really exciting to be here.
Go ahead, a little applause
might be nice up front.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
The first reframe that I want
to give you around storytelling
is this.
Stories are products.
They could be monetized.
They can make you money.
And the Google story is
pretty interesting, right?
1995, Sergey Brin and Larry
Page met each other at Stanford.
Start to collaborate,
developed a friendship.
They're both technology guys.
They decided yeah, we've
got something in common.
And in 1996, they had created
their first search engine.
And this is probably
the first search engine
that had ever occurred
anywhere in the world.
It was a new concept, new idea.
At Stanford University,
it was called Back Rub.
And so here they are
developing this thing,
and it's really
successful at Stanford,
and the students are
using it, and everybody's
thinking it's really cool.
But it took too much bandwidth
over the computer system,
and so they had to
rework it a little bit.
And in 1997, I
believe it is, they
decided we need a new name.
Back Rub is kind of weird.
That's not the right name.
And they came up with Google.
They went out and bought
the domain name google.com.
And over a period of time, they
started to realize this is hot.
This is amazing.
This is good technology.
We need to do
something with this.
And that's where story came in.
They knew they had to go sit
down with venture capital
people, somebody who could give
them some money because they
knew they didn't have
the money themselves.
They had to find somebody
who could fund this idea.
And so they went
out, and they started
talking to different people.
And they ended up getting lucky.
There was this guy
named Andy Bechtolsheim
at Sun Microsystems.
And they sat down across
the table with him,
and they told the story of a
vision they had for a search
engine technology that
would allow people
to find any
information anywhere.
Now, this didn't exist outside
of Stanford at that time,
and it was a new
concept and a new idea.
And they had to
paint this picture
in Andy's mind of
what this would be.
They told the story.
They walked out of that
meeting with a $100,000 check.
Are stories products?
Did they sell that story?
Did it monetize their business?
Yes.
And so what I want you to
understand about story today
is with this story
theater method,
we're going to expand
the ability for you
to engage and inform
and entertain and grab
people's attention with this
story theater method, which
is a combination of what I
learned in Hollywood doing
Shakespeare and studying movies
and business presentations.
Because storytelling and
business is very serious
business.
So here's the exercise
that I want you to do.
Recall a childhood memory
or your favorite movie.
Five seconds.
OK, you've got something.
It happened just that fast.
Am I right?
Did something pop up for you?
Yes or no.
It happens just that fast.
Your brain goes on a Google
search of your entire life
for all of the movies and all
of the childhood memories,
and [POP] something pops up.
Now, what just happened?
When you recalled
that childhood memory,
when you recalled that movie,
your movie screen popped up,
and what did you see?
Did you see a
picture, yes or no?
Yes?
Did you see a picture?
Did you see a scene?
If it was from a movie, did
you see the scene in the movie?
So here's what I need to do.
I need some interactivity here.
I need one person to
share childhood memory
and what you saw, and one person
to share what was the movie
and what did you see.
So somebody raise your hand.
I'll point to you, and give
me an idea what you got.
What do you got?
AUDIENCE: My
childhood memory was
with friends riding Big Wheels
down the street on my hill.
DOUG STEVENSON: OK.
How old were you in this memory?
How far back does this go?
AUDIENCE: Grade school.
DOUG STEVENSON: Grade school.
So six, seven,
eight years of age?
AUDIENCE: Something like that.
DOUG STEVENSON: OK.
Can you see that right now?
Can you describe to
me what you're seeing?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DOUG STEVENSON: Describe it.
AUDIENCE: We're outside.
It's a nice, bright sunny day.
There's a lot of people smiling.
We're on our Big Wheels.
There's people falling down.
There's people racing
back up the hill.
There's a lot of activity.
It's kind of loud.
It's a lot of fun.
We're by ourselves.
There's no parental supervision.
It's kind of dangerous.
It's exciting.
DOUG STEVENSON: All right.
Do you hear the
energy going on here?
And why can he give me
this in such detail?
He is watching the
movie right now.
Would you agree?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DOUG STEVENSON: You're
literally watching this movie
and going step by step by step.
While he's looking at
me with his eyes on me,
he is watching a
movie internally.
Vision out, vision
in, at the same time.
Amazing, amazing technology.
This gray matter in
here, pretty interesting.
Now, thank you very much.
Somebody with the childhood
memory-- or the movie.
Somebody with the movie,
please raise your hand
and give me something.
AUDIENCE: Transformers,
the animated movie.
And I just remember when
my friends at this age
knew it so well that
we were reciting
the lines from the
movie and going
through the different scenes.
DOUG STEVENSON: So you
actually can recite it.
It's memorable.
AUDIENCE: Yep.
DOUG STEVENSON: And because
you can see the scene
and visualize the characters
and the environment,
you can remember what
was going on inside that.
Am I correct?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
DOUG STEVENSON: And so this
is what happens to your brain.
Literally, story is the most
important communication tool
you can have in your
tool belt if you
want to be memorable, if
you want to be persuasive.
Now, if you don't
want to be memorable,
if you want to
just flap your lips
and say a whole bunch of stuff
in a room and people walk out
and go delete, and they go on
with their business and nothing
changes, then you
don't need story.
But if you want to be
memorable, like that movie
and all of those scenes
and all of that detail,
then you need to be
masterful with story.
Now, here's the thing about
everybody's memory just now.
Why that childhood memory?
Why that movie?
Because it was an
emotionally charged event.
Would you agree that
that childhood memory
had some joy or sorrow,
pleasure or pain, at some level?
For those of you who had a
childhood memory, yes or no?
Was it an emotionally
charged event?
OK.
The movie, was that
a joyous movie?
Did you really dig that movie?
It was fun?
So if you had a movie,
why do you remember it?
Because it was a cool movie.
Because I dug it.
Because while I was
watching that, it was fun.
It was exciting.
We don't remember things that
aren't emotionally charged.
So if you've ever given a
boring presentation that
was filled with all
kinds of incredible data
and it didn't stick,
that's because there
was no emotional connection.
You know what the
number one reason
I'm hired to go out and work
with companies and individuals
and teams?
They want the
emotional connection.
Because they understand
intellectually that
if I don't make an
emotional connection,
the stuff doesn't stick.
Would you agree?
It's that emotional connection.
And your data and
your PowerPoint slides
very seldom do that.
But you know if I
do PowerPoint slides
with imagery and
pictures, am I right?
You have a better shot
at being memorable.
So on your handout, page one.
I want to read a
little bit of a quote.
And this is the book that
we're talking about here today.
This is the author.
Doug Stevenson's
"Story Theater Method."
So the quote on this page
from the book "Brain Rules"
by John Medina.
One important area
of research is
the effect of
emotion on learning.
Emotionally arousing events
tend to be better remembered
than neutral events.
They persist much
longer in our memories
and recalled with greater
accuracy than neutral events.
Emotion is the fast
lane to the brain.
If you can infuse your
presentation with emotion--
and I don't mean you got
to stand up here and cry,
but I mean you get into it.
You have some energy.
You have some emotion.
You're charged by the story.
And if it's a personal story,
it has that emotion in it.
So emotion is the fast
lane to the brain.
Now, down at the
bottom of the page,
I'm going to talk to
you about the five areas
that the story
theater method takes
your story to the
next level with.
But I want to reframe
something as well.
I want you to think of
the story theater method
as an app for storytelling.
Now, I don't know about you,
but when I just recently got
my iPhone, and I had an Android
before that, the Android,
the iPhone, the
BlackBerry, would you
agree that's an amazing
communication tool?
I mean, just out of the
box, it's already awesome.
It just does all
these cool things.
But when does it become really
awesome for you in particular?
When you start downloading the
apps that are specific to you.
Would you agree?
So who's got Yelp?
Anybody got Yelp?
I love Yelp.
It helps me right here because
I don't know where I am.
I could find restaurants.
I found a sushi
place last night.
So cool.
Google Maps.
Oh my gosh.
I got lost yesterday.
I went for a six mile run.
I found a running trail.
I could map the run
with Map My Run.
So I could see where am I
going, and how's my heartbeat,
and how far have I gone.
And then I got lost on
the way back to my hotel,
so I thought, oh my
god, Google Maps.
Oh, there I am.
It's like, this is
just awesome stuff.
Well, the apps make your iPhone,
your smartphone, unique to you,
and they take your
iPhone to the next level.
The story theater method takes
storytelling to another level
because it makes it more
visual, more three-dimensional.
So at the bottom of the page,
the story theater method,
strategic storytelling.
First of all, you're going
to learn how to choose today,
how to choose the right
story for the right moment.
There are all kinds
of different stories.
ConAgra wanted me to help them
with their emerging leaders
to not be so technical in their
presentations, not so boring.
Microsoft wanted me to
help them find the stories
for their sales presentations.
Lockheed Martin wanted me to
help their executives not go in
and give these briefings that
just put everybody to sleep.
Everybody's got a
different use for it,
but there's a different
story for every different use
and utility.
It's like every story is a
different kind of an app.
How to craft your stories
to make them memorable.
That's the nine steps of story
structure in the story theater
method that I'm going
to share with you today.
How to craft the story.
It's not enough to have
an interesting story.
It is not enough to just
think, oh I've got this story.
I'll just tell it.
Have you ever had the
experience that in your mind,
you had this really good story?
It was in your head, and it
was brilliant in the shower.
And you thought, this is
going to work in this meeting.
And then you get
up and you start
telling that story,
and [INAUDIBLE],
it just starts coming
out of your mouth.
And you forget things, and
you go out of sequence.
Am I the only one who's
ever had this happen?
And you delete a critical
piece of the story.
And you don't know you
deleted it till 7/8 of the way
through the story.
And you go, oh my god,
it won't make any sense
without that piece.
I'll insert it now.
Does that work?
Come on, tell me.
No.
Say no.
It doesn't work because if
you go out of sequence, if you
don't have the right
craft, it doesn't work.
So the nine steps of story
helps you to do that.
How to identify one
clear and concise point.
I'm going to share with
you a little information
about the phrase that
pays today and how
to perform your stories
for maximum impact.
I'm going to perform a
couple of stories today,
and you're going to see how
this story theater method allows
the story to become
three-dimensional.
So do I have any
actors in the room?
Anybody ever done any acting?
Yes?
See some hands.
The videographer.
Oh yay!
I got one person over here.
Anybody do any stand up comedy?
How about go to a
barbecue and have a beer?
You become a good actor
at a barbecue with a beer?
If I could capture you
on video after work,
you're no longer
on stage, you're
just goofing off with friends.
You've had a glass of wine.
You've had a beer.
Oh my god, I got to
tell you what happened.
Oh my gosh, all of a sudden
you're like three-dimensional.
Then you come up and give
a business presentation.
What happens?
[WHOOSHING NOISE] I am cool.
I'm professional.
So the story theater
method allows
it to be more theatrical,
which becomes more engaging.
And then finally, how to
make your stories pay.
How do you monetize your story?
What is a job promotion worth?
You get a promotion
for a job, and you
get an increase in salary.
Which leads to
another job promotion,
another increase in salary.
Over 20 years,
what is that worth?
Add it up.
One of my students
came to me, and he
was going to be in a
venture capital competition.
They get 10 minutes
to walk into this room
and do their presentation.
They wanted to work on the
story for this venture capital
presentation.
There was a competition.
There was always other people
coming in for 10 minutes.
You get to come in.
There's these people with
checkbook sitting there.
It's like, come in, do your
10 minutes, walk out the door.
They came to me and worked
on their story theater
story of this vision that
they had for this startup
company right here in
the Silicon Valley.
They walked into that room.
They did their 10 minutes.
And they won $25 million.
What is your story worth?
Because your personal
story, that story
you have some idea, some vision,
you can monetize that story.
You can change the world, and
you can change your own life.
Now, anybody here want
to change the world
while making a lot of money?
Anybody?
I don't know about
you, but I like
to be able to pay my
mortgage and change
your life at the same time.
I have another student who
came to me, and she said,
you know what?
I'm going to be a
motivational speaker someday,
but right now I'm a nurse.
But I got this awesome story.
We worked on that story.
She has built a multimillion
dollar speaking and consulting
business on the basis of
one really awesome story.
I had another guy who came
to me and he said, you know,
I'm making these presentations
because the economy's gone sour
on me.
And I'm making
these presentations,
but they're not working.
And I think I'm telling stories.
I worked with him for
an hour on his stories.
His closing ratio
went from 2% to 40%
after one hour of working on
the strategic use of story
in a presentation.
How do you monetize
your stories?
What are your stories worth?
They're worth a lot of money.
So let's go to page three.
Move it or lose them,
chapter 17 in my book.
What happens to the audience
while you are telling a story?
Well, let me perform a story.
We'll see what happens.
Back in 1998, I
got a phone call.
I was sitting in my office.
The phone rang.
It was a speaker's bureau.
And she called me
up to let me know
that I'd been chosen to do the
after dinner keynote speech
outside of Kansas City
in Overland Park, Kansas.
The Positive Power of
Change keynote speech.
And she said the meeting
planner wants to talk to you.
She wants to make sure
you're on the same page.
Give her a call.
So I called her up,
and she said, oh, I
am in charge of everything.
I don't do this kind of thing.
But this is the annual meeting.
It's a really big deal.
So you have to be at the
front desk at 5:30 PM.
I'm going to pick
you up, and we're
going to drive down
to the restaurant.
We're going to get set up, and
I've got to do registration.
I've got to work with the
caterers and the [INAUDIBLE].
Could you be-- you have
to be there at 5:30 PM.
OK, OK.
5:30 PM.
I'll be at the front desk.
Fine.
I was thinking to myself
when I hung up the phone,
OK so she's not picking
me up until 5:30 PM.
Man, if I fly in
the day before, I'm
going to waste the entire day.
I never get anything done.
I'm so bad on the road.
Why am I so bad?
How many times can
I go to the gym?
I read "USA Today"?
How many times can
I get a pedicure?
But I had a rule.
And I think you guys
all have the same rule.
If you're a business
traveler, do you ever
fly in for a meeting on the
same day as the meeting?
It's a bad idea.
Am I right?
But I was thinking
maybe it's possible
because this isn't LA to Boston.
This is Colorado
Springs to Kansas City.
Middle of the country to
the middle of the country.
I thought, maybe it's possible.
I'll call my travel agent.
You could tell how old
I am because I was even
using a travel agent.
Travel agent.
Yeah.
Hi, Carol?
I'm good.
How are you?
Yes.
Uh huh, another booking, yeah.
Kansas City.
August 28.
Actually, Carol, could
you look on the 28?
I know, I know.
I have a rule.
2:30?
Really, 2:30?
Well, no.
She's not picking
me up until 5:30.
It would give me three hours.
Ah, is there a backup?
There is.
OK.
Mm, OK.
What's the routing?
Through O'Hare.
OK.
All right.
Just give me just a sec.
Don't do this.
OK, let's do this.
OK fine.
Thanks.
I don't know why, but I
just felt good about this.
I thought, this time
it's going to work.
Positive Power Change.
I mean, that's what I do.
So on the day of the booking,
I went to the airport.
Took off on time, flying
through the friendly skies, land
at O'Hare airport, walk out
into concourse B. OK, concourse
B. Departure board,
departure board.
OK, there we go.
Des Moines, Jacksonville,
Kansas City.
B18 delayed.
Oh, man.
It's delayed an hour.
OK, well it's only
delayed an hour.
Instead of 2:30, I
get there at 3:30.
Still two hours.
Not bad.
Went to the Red Carpet Club.
Had an hour to kill.
Came back, looked at the
departure board again.
Red Carpet Club,
departure board, B18.
Delayed again.
Finally, finally, I get
a flight out of Chicago
into Kansas City.
The plane had pulled
up to the gate.
It is on the ground,
pulling up to the gate.
4:45.
Oh my god.
What did she say?
At rush hour,
there's very seldom
enough taxis at the
airport, but there's always
the little blue
super shuttle bus.
They run every half hour.
4:45.
You do the math.
I'm sitting in my seat.
Row 28.
Window seat.
I am literally in the
last seat on the plane.
I've got 15 minutes,
if there are no taxis,
to get all the way out
to get to the curb.
What are my chances?
Ha ha ha.
The positive power change.
OK, come on.
Let's go down the aisle, people,
let's move it down the aisle.
OK, come on.
Positive power-- oh
my god, 12 minutes.
Come on, positive power change.
Are you kidding me, lady?
Is that your entire life?
Have you ever flown--
you rookie, jeez.
OK, all right.
Good, good, good.
Here we go.
OK.
All right.
Positive power of change.
Hit the-- [INAUDIBLE].
Come on.
Finally, I get off the plane.
Luggage carousel,
luggage carousel.
OK, OK.
Five minutes.
OK.
Come on, come on.
I finally get to the curb.
[INAUDIBLE]
5:00.
Whoa, shuttle bus.
No taxis.
Positive power of change.
What do we teach?
Reframe the situation.
Change represents an
opportunity for something
better to take
place in your life.
No taxis.
That's my shuttle bus.
5:05.
This is an opportunity
for something
better to take place in my life.
[INAUDIBLE]
And then I see it sitting
right in front of my face.
Literally, I've been
looking over the roof
of a long white stretch limo.
Sitting right there.
I'm thinking, opportunity.
I look over, and
the trunk is open.
And there's this
short little guy.
He looks like Danny
DeVito in polyester.
He's just closing the
trunk and getting back.
Hi, excuse me.
Are you by any chance going
to Overland Park, Kansas?
I've got to get a ride.
I'm a motivational speaker, and
I've got to get a ride tonight.
It's an emergency.
There's no taxis.
Can you give me a ride?
This might be your lucky day.
Really?
Why is it my lucky-- guy he
was supposed to give a ride to,
his flight got
canceled, and I was just
going to [INAUDIBLE] head back.
Can we work something out?
You've got $20.
I do have $20.
Give me the $20.
I give the man $20.
He takes my luggage.
I'm sitting in the
back of a limo.
I'm thinking to myself--
[SNAPS FINGERS]
I'm thinking, this is so cool.
I mean, the positive
power of change.
Reframe the situation.
Change represents
an opportunity.
It actually is true.
Oh my gosh.
So now we're having
a conversation.
You drive with limo
drivers, taxi drivers.
Uh, you know, buddy, it's a good
thing you missed that shuttle.
I used to drive
for that company.
There's eight hotels
on that route.
I believe, if I
recall, yours would've
been about number seven.
It's rush hour.
You never would have
got there on time
if you caught that shuttle.
But because you
got a ride with me,
I've got an alternate route.
I can get you there on time.
So the next time you
come to the airport, man,
don't look for the shuttle.
Look for the limo.
Oh, that's good.
Well, I went and
gave the speech.
I mean, 5:29, he literally
drops me off at the hotel lobby.
I give the speech.
Everything goes great.
But the next day, as I'm flying
home, I'm sitting on the plane.
Kind of in that half awake, half
dazed, half sleepy thing kind
of going over what
happened yesterday
and going over and over in my
head like a mantra from a guru.
Don't look for the shuttle, man.
Look for the limo.
Oh my gosh, look for the limo.
Well, it just was
such a cool message
because this is the
metaphor for my life.
When things go
wrong, if you focus
on solutions rather than
problems, if you look
for the opportunity,
they're there.
You got to look for the limo, or
else it's not going to appear.
Now, how about you?
Have you ever had a project that
doesn't go according to plan?
Yes or no.
You ever had something in your
life not go according to plan?
Your first divorce?
Second divorce?
Your teenagers?
My challenge for
you is the next time
things aren't go
according to plan, focus
on solutions rather
than problems.
In other words,
look for the limo.
Say that with me, nice and loud.
Look for the limo.
Oh my gosh, that's
story theater.
Now, is that engaging?
Did you watch the movie in
your mind just now, yes or no?
Yes or no, did you see it?
Did you participate in it?
Here is the really
cool thing about this.
Where did you forget
that you were sitting
out there watching
me tell a story?
And without knowing it, you
slipped inside the story,
and you were in it somewhere.
You're literally in one
of the environments.
You were feeling
an emotional state.
So I need three people, very
quickly, raise your hand.
I'll point to you.
Where were you inside the story?
Right there, what do you got?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DOUG STEVENSON:
How about row 28?
Was anybody back there with me?
Oh, my gosh.
Did you get some anxiety?
You probably got some anxiety.
And how many of you were
also ticked off at that lady?
I have had a lot of people
go, I hate that lady.
I think, you're listening
to me tell the story,
but you had hate in
your heart while you're
listening to me tell the story
because that lady is driving
you nuts?
Where else we're
you in the story?
Thank you very much.
Where else?
Two more people.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DOUG STEVENSON: Talking
to Danny DeVito.
So I'm at the curb, and I
got the dialogue going on.
So you're kind of seeing that.
You're seeing the curb.
Where else?
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DOUG STEVENSON: Super shuttle.
And oh, my gosh.
That sense-- now, was
there emotion connected
to these scenes
that you were in?
Yes or no.
Did you feel it?
Did you have joy and
sorrow and frustration?
Did you laugh?
Did you feel it?
Yes or no.
Because you did.
You cannot-- this is the thing
about story theater that is
so compelling.
You cannot not go with
me into these scenes.
You cannot not do it.
And it doesn't matter
where you're from.
And this is the beauty
of story theater.
It is a universal language.
I have done this
all over the world.
I even did this in Japan
with a Japanese interpreter,
and people still got it.
I have done it in Malaysia.
I've done it in Spain.
I've done it all over
the United States.
It is the universal language
because it is theater.
It is behavior.
It is not just telling a story.
It is showing and
telling a story.
Now this is the app that
takes story to the next level.
So here's the question.
What's your story?
And is it worth
working on this story
and making it a little
bit more colorful
so that you can
monetize that story
and turn that into a
million dollar story?
Because your story can
take you to the next place,
but at the same time it can
influence and persuade people
to go to the next place.
But they won't do it if they
just hear it and understand it.
Understanding a concept does
not change hearts, minds,
and behavior.
It does not get people
to write a check.
It does not get people to
say, OK, you've convinced me.
All right, I'm going to
go along with your idea.
Now, there's got be
something more compelling.
So the idea here-- and
at the top of page three,
you can see what I'm asking for.
The visuals, when
you're creating a story,
you need to make it visual.
So I want you right now to all
identify in your mind a story
that you would like to be
more amazing, more colorful.
So if you're watching
this on video, on YouTube
or on the feed,
what is that story
that you'd like to make more
amazing, more colorful, more
compelling, more
emotionally dynamic?
So just think about
that for a second.
You got something?
Now, I want you
to visualize when
you were experiencing
that event in your life.
You are in environments,
am I right?
You're in specific physical
places with other people.
Those are the environments that
you create with story theater.
Did you notice when
I did my story,
it became a
three-dimensional space?
What were some of the
three-dimensional spaces
that you saw me create for you
that you literally saw yourself
in those spaces with me?
Who can give me an idea?
You saw a physical environment.
What was it?
The airplane.
So you saw the airplane.
Did you see the aisle?
Did you see people in front
of you, stacked on the aisle?
Yes or no.
Yeah?
You were there, right?
So you saw an airplane.
What other physical
environment did I create?
On the phone.
Was anybody with me when
I was on the phone going,
don't do this.
Did anybody get a
little plugged in there?
Oh my gosh.
Most people say,
that was just nuts.
I've done that.
So if I can create those moments
and create those environments
and create those scenes and
do them, not talk about them,
you go into it with me, and
you get the emotional hook,
the emotional trigger.
What is one other
environment that you saw?
The curb.
So I got the curb.
I've got the office where
I'm making the phone call.
Got the back of the plane.
Got the luggage carousel.
I've got the departure
board in concourse B.
I've got all of
these environments.
So look at your story
in your mind right now.
What are the environments that
your story takes place in?
Make it visual.
Make your story visual.
Move.
Use some space.
Make it three-dimensional.
That's when it
becomes story theater.
And when you take that
step, they go with you.
Would you agree?
Did you go with me
when I did that?
Now, some of you out
here are probably
very, very techy brains.
And I don't mean that
disparagingly at all
because oh my gosh, do we need
this type-- but you know what?
When I say to you
make it visual,
some of you who are a
little bit more introverted,
a little bit more
in your head, might
say but I'm not very physical.
Here's my challenge.
Do you want them to be physical?
Do you want them to feel it?
Then you've got to go
to that next level.
You've got to make it visual.
Now, the next piece on
here is make it emotional.
Make it emotional.
What emotions did you
feel during this story?
Did you feel anxiety?
Did you feel joy at the
end when I made it on time
and I gave the speech?
Yes!
Did you feel happy when I
was riding along in the limo?
I was like, whoo, woohoo.
Did you go with me on my
emotional roller coaster?
Because you probably did.
You go where I take you.
You don't have a choice.
90% of every audience will
go right there with you.
I've often described this as
kind of like bungee jumping.
You don't kind of.
You jump.
When you commit to telling a
story at this level, you go.
And they come with you.
And it doesn't matter what
it feels like out there.
You are committed to doing this.
It's a mini piece of theater.
Now, the next one here is make
one clear and concise point
with every story.
And here's where story
strategy comes in.
When you choose your
story, you immediately
have to say what is the one
clear and concise simple
point that I want to
make with this story.
So when you get to
the end of the story,
you do not go on for
three or four or five
sentences about
what I learned was,
and then you go through
this litany of things.
No, you get to the
end and say, what
I learned was look for the limo.
When things don't go
right, look for the limo.
Now, that is a phrase that pays.
That is part of the storytelling
technology of story theater.
It is very strategic.
It is very targeted.
I don't get to
tell any story that
makes a whole bunch of points.
It is very, very specific.
It is one app that
does one thing well.
And that's how you influence
and persuade people to change.
You focus their attention.
So I want you to see in
the middle of the page
where it says visualize scenes.
As you are creating
your stories,
I don't want you to just keep
thinking about the sequence.
This happened, and
then this happened.
Then I said this, and
Then I said that, and
then this happened.
And she said this.
Then I went over here.
That's just telling.
And that stays in the head.
You need to visualize
the scenes that you
were in where the
drama was taking place,
and you need to play
within those scenes.
So now we're going to talk
about the advanced story theater
performance techniques.
Story strategy.
Use a specific story to make
one clear and concise point.
Years ago I realized I
get hired all the time
by very, very
frustrated clients who
are giving very, very dull, dry
technical presentations, full
of very good information.
But they put their listeners
into a content coma.
Have you ever done this
with a presentation?
Have you ever put your
audience into a content coma?
Say yes.
I know some of you have.
Because it's like
such good content.
But oh my gosh, it's
so much content.
Anybody besides me ever give a
presentation where you've got
three hours' worth of content
in a 20 minute presentation?
Yes?
Oh my gosh, this is a
crime against humanity.
This is a problem.
So I get hired by people all
the time for this one reason.
I thought, I need a
story that illustrates
what I do with these clients
to put up on my website
so that more people will listen
to the story of what I do,
understand what I
do, and hire me.
I want to monetize my
business with the right story.
Well, I didn't have
the story, so I
went on a story safari,
what I call a Google
search for the right story.
I need a story that teaches
what I do with technology where
I help people to make their
content more interesting.
Oh, here's the story.
How many people
have dogs or cats?
Got any people with pets?
Some of you don't have pets.
You've got kids?
You'll probably relate to this.
Even if you don't have dogs
or cats, go with me on this.
I grew up with
dogs, Irish setters.
My dad was into Irish setters.
And we had Irish
setter-- we had Dawn.
We had Penny.
And as a kid, I always had dogs.
And I thought, this is so cool.
Because when you're a kid, you
just get to play with the dogs.
But your parents
take care of them.
They're the ones
who spend the money.
Am I right?
So as a kid, it's
like, this is great.
Well, as an adult,
all of a sudden I
realized I want my own dog.
So I went out, and I got
this little black lab puppy.
Six weeks old, just
this little ball
of fat and fur
and just adorable.
And I named her Jaya,
and I raised her.
And she was just adorable.
She was my best friend.
When I was down in
Hollywood, I needed a buddy.
Well, about two years into this
relationship with this dog,
she got sick.
I'd never had to deal with this
before, but all of a sudden
she was very lethargic.
She wasn't eating her food.
And I thought, something's
going on with this dog.
Jaya is not good.
I got to take her to the vet.
So for the first time
I'd ever had to do this,
I took her to the vet.
He diagnosed her.
He said, yep, she's got a cold.
She's a little bit sick.
Here's some pills.
Give her a pill at breakfast
and a pill at dinner.
[INAUDIBLE]
Thought, so easy.
Just give her a
pill at breakfast.
So that night at
dinner, I was going
to give her a pill I
said, come on, Jaya.
Jaya, Jaya.
I know.
Come on.
Come here.
Good girl.
Sit.
I know.
You don't feel very well.
Hi.
I know.
I've got to give you a pill.
What did he tell me to do?
OK, so Jaya, I've got
to pull your mouth open.
I've got to shove this down
into the back of your throat,
and I'm going to hold it, and
you're going to swallow it.
Yeah.
Come on.
Why are you looking
at me like that?
Come on, swallow the pill.
OK, what did he say?
OK.
If she just looks at
you, massage her throat.
Massage the throat.
Good girl.
So did you swallow it?
Uck.
So she spits up the
pill on my hands.
It's like, this is ridiculous.
I tried this three more times.
I went through four pills.
They cost a lot of money.
Am I right?
Oh my gosh.
They cost a lot of money.
Anybody here have kids
who are a little bit
fussy with their pills?
Dogs, cats, gerbils, pythons?
So anyway, I was really
frustrated with this.
I figured, who knows
how to do this?
I called my friend John.
I said John, you've had
dogs your entire life.
What do you do?
You got any peanut butter?
John, do you need
some peanut butter?
Are you asking for me to
bring some peanut butter over?
No, no, no.
Do you have some peanut butter?
Yeah, I've got peanut butter.
Hide the pill in
the peanut butter.
I see some heads nodding.
I thought, this is so strange.
Hide the pill in
the peanut butter.
But I did it.
I went and I got
some peanut butter
and I scooped it
into my palm and I
put the pill inside
the peanut butter.
I went over to Jaya.
Come here, Jaya.
Come on.
You want something?
[INAUDIBLE]
Yes!
Oh, good girl.
Well, I hid to pill
in the peanut butter,
and the medicine went down.
Hide the pill in
the peanut butter.
What is the pill?
The pill is all that
information that you've
got in a presentation
that is so hard to swallow
for the listener's brain
because it's just too much.
And sometimes it's
too dry and technical.
Would you agree?
The pill is good medicine.
It's good information.
And yet it's hard for
their brain to swallow it.
Would you agree, yes or no?
Because sometimes it's
just like, oh my god.
I get this.
Why don't they get this?
Because you're brilliant,
and they're not you.
That's why.
And so when you are coming
up with a whole bunch of data
that you need to put
into a presentation,
my counsel for you is to hide
the pill, the good medicine,
in the story butter.
Because the peanut
butter sticks.
The story sticks.
That story is the
strategic use of a story
to make a specific point.
Did you see the dog?
Did you see me
giving her the pill?
Did you feel it?
Did you feel the saliva?
Anybody?
So that's story
theater once again.
The strategic use of a story
to do a specific thing.
I can tell you for a fact.
I've put that up on my
home page on my website.
I now get calls from clients
from all over the world that
used to come to my
website and keep going.
Now they come to my website.
They watch that video,
they pick up the phone,
and they talk to me.
That's monetizing your story.
That's a million dollar story.
How much is your story worth?
Now, the next one
here is in moments,
acting or reenacting
moments in your story.
The in moments, the acting
out of these moments
like playing with the dog,
going to the back of the plane,
getting off the plane, being
at the luggage carousel,
being at the curb.
I call them in moments.
And literally, here's where
the theater in story theater
comes in.
In story theater, I take
moments in my story,
and I go back to when I was
an actor on a stage in a play,
and I'm in a present tense
recreation of a moment in time.
Then I step back out, and
I'm talking to the audience,
and I'm narrating my story.
And then I step back into a
moment, playing with the dog.
Then I step back out.
I'm talking to you.
So that's the story theater.
Very simple.
Emotions.
Showing emotions rather
than describing them.
The emotional connection
that you're looking for
is that you don't
describe emotions.
You get into them.
You feel them.
You show them with your body.
And you do this after you've
had a beer at a barbecue anyway,
so you know how to do it.
Three dimensions, using
staging and movement
to create imaginary
environments,
going back and
forth and creating
a three-dimensional stage.
Dialogue, adding
two-person dialogue,
like the dialogue that I
had with my little Danny
DeVito, the limo driver, or
the telephone conversation.
This is the stuff that
makes story come alive.
So I want you to think
about that story right now,
and what is the dialogue
that is in that story?
Who are you having
a conversation with?
Don't just tell me
about the conversation.
Do the conversation.
Dialogue makes stories awesome.
It really makes them come alive.
And finally, [INAUDIBLE]
their message
branding, using a
phrase that pays.
At the bottom of
the page it says,
and this is a
quote from my book,
a speaker's job is to
deliver information
in a way that motivates people
to listen, remember, and act.
Here's the greatest
challenge that you
face in your presentations,
internally or externally.
If you go in and you
make a presentation,
the person that
you're speaking to
is going to take action later on
based on whether they remember
anything from your
presentation or not.
They're not necessarily going to
change their mind in the room,
that their behavior
changes later on.
You have to be memorable.
And if you give a presentation
and you're not memorable,
you're dead in the water.
So I want you to think about
a presentation you've made,
you've listened to, you've
been participating in,
in the last 24 hours where
you've been in the audience
for a presentation.
What do you remember?
Come on.
Give me something.
What do you remember
from a presentation?
Any presentation you've been
in in the last 24 hours.
Somebody give me a specific
thing that you remember.
I need three people.
What do you got?
AUDIENCE: Feeling
bored out of my mind.
DOUG STEVENSON: Feeling
Now, was that what
the presenter wanted?
I don't think so.
So your sense is, oh
my god, this sucks.
I am so bored.
This is terrible.
This is pathetic.
This person doesn't get it.
He doesn't know
how to engage me.
That's frustration.
That's not learning anything.
That's being a
little bit ticked off
that this person doesn't get it.
Who can remember content?
Yeah, what do you got?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DOUG STEVENSON:
A student who had
been admitted into a university.
In other words,
are you telling me
that you're remembering
somebody telling
a story about a student?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DOUG STEVENSON: You're
remembering a story.
Can you see that right now?
Here's the challenge.
I ask you, what do you
remember from a presentation
within the last 24 hours.
Nobody raises their
hand and says,
there was this
incredible concept.
It's like, eh, the content
just goes flopping away.
This is scary.
OK, next page.
Page five.
How to choose your stories.
Here we go.
You start with
the point in mind.
You start by thinking, what
do I need a story to do?
Story is a utility.
Story is a vehicle that
accomplishes something.
What do I need a story to teach?
You start with a point in mind.
That's where you start.
And then you go
on a story safari.
Look for a moment of crisis,
challenge, or obstacle.
So I want you to understand
that you're always
looking for the iceberg moment.
When I say look for
the iceberg moment,
what do you think
I'm talking about?
What is the iceberg
moment related to?
Titanic.
You know what the story of
Titanic is without the iceberg?
It's a cruise ship.
It's just a big
cruise ship, and it's
going from England to New York.
And it's just a cruise ship.
Without the iceberg,
do we have a story?
Not really.
But with the iceberg,
OK we got something.
What is the iceberg
moment in your story?
There's got to be a crisis,
an obstacle, or a challenge.
So you're always
looking for stories
that have this pain, this
challenge, this frustration.
The moment doesn't have to
be profound or dramatic.
I want you to think about the
stories that I told you today.
One was a story about
giving my dog a pill.
Oh my gosh.
Is this profound?
No, it's ordinary,
everyday stuff.
But with craft, it
becomes something.
My airport story.
Has anybody else ever
had a delayed flight?
So is this profound?
No.
But with craft, it
becomes something.
The story teaches
us a better way
to think about something or
a better way to do something.
The story portrays an event that
has special meaning, perhaps
a turning point in your life.
Now, here is how you start
with the point in mind
and go on a Google
search for that story.
If you start to search, you say
I want a story about empathy.
I need a story about integrity.
I need a story about innovation.
So you start with
that point in mind.
You go, OK, I'm going to
search my life for innovation,
innovation.
Ah, I got nothing.
Ah, I got-- well you
know what you're doing?
You're doing a Google
search of your entire life,
but you forgot to put some
words in the search box.
Here is the word you
put in the search box.
Innovation, where was I living
when I was 30 years of age?
So what you're doing
is you're going back
to a specific
moment in your life.
So you go back to
where were you living.
You go back to an address.
And then you scan, while I was
at that address, what happened?
Is there anything that happened
while I was in that apartment
or in that house when I
was 30 years of age that
had anything to do
with innovation?
No.
How about my job when I was 30?
What job did I have?
What boss did I have?
What team was I on?
Anything to do with innovation?
OK, what about my relationships?
I was in a relationship with--
who was I in a relationship
with?
And you're basically going to
a specific moment in your life
and scanning that moment
in your life for something
around innovation.
If you don't find
anything at 30, 32.
Where was I living?
35, where was I living?
40, where was I living?
And you keep doing
this, but you have
to put search terms in the
Google box of your brain.
And that will help you
to identify a story.
So I'm going to answer a
couple of questions for you
before we end here that
are common questions that I
hear from everybody.
Which comes first, the
story or the point?
In storytelling and business,
strategic storytelling
and business,
basically I'm always
looking from the point of I
need a story to do something.
So I start with
the point in mind.
But occasionally, occasionally
something happens to me
like this airport story
with the Kansas City airport
and missing the shuttle
bus and the limo.
And after something
like that happens,
because I'm a story
guy, because I'm always
coming from theater and
metaphor, something like that
happens and I'm sitting
back going, huh.
That's interesting.
I thought that the best outcome
would be to either get a taxi,
but there weren't any,
so to get the shuttle
would be a positive outcome,
and I'd get there on time.
Didn't get taxi.
Didn't get shuttle.
Got a limo.
Limo's better.
Why would I be disappointed
about missing a shuttle bus
and getting a limo?
I should be happy that I
missed the shuttle bus.
And I start playing with the
concept, the metaphor of this,
and I go, ah, now I have to
find out what's the point.
So if you've got a story
from your life and think,
this is cool stuff.
What's the utility?
What's the point?
You have to then go
to, what's the point?
You don't get to tell it if
it doesn't have a right point.
Which is better, personal
stories or stories
about other people?
Well, let's take a vote.
When you're listening to
a story from a speaker,
from a presenter, somebody
in your organization,
which one plugs you in more?
Them telling a story about
something in their life,
or them telling a story
about somebody else?
So personal story,
they're telling you
a personal story, who
thinks that's better?
Well that's basically
95% of the room.
So you just answered
the question.
You need to be willing to
share stories from your life.
You need to be willing
to share stories
where you messed up
and learned a lesson.
Here's the challenge.
You are bringing
wisdom to that lesson.
You're bringing wisdom to
that pain or that challenge.
So you're not saying basically,
boy I screw up a lot.
No, you're saying I
was doing this thing.
It didn't turn out the way I
thought it was supposed to.
I learned this
wonderful lesson, and I
want to share that
wisdom with you
so I can spare you some pain.
So personal stories are best.
That doesn't mean you can't
have other types of stories.
I'm going to share with you
other types in just a second.
Does the story have to be
true or can you embellish?
Yes.
Yes, the story has to be true.
Here's the test of any
story that you tell.
If somebody walks up to
you after your presentation
and says, did that
really happen to you?
What does your answer have
to be to be integrity?
Yes, that really happened to me.
Can you embellish the
story and it still be true?
Yes.
Oh my gosh, yes.
Do you want to get a laugh?
Embellish.
Have some fun.
I don't remember when I was
at the back of the plane.
If there was a lady whose entire
life was in the overhead bin
and in her luggage, I don't
remember that specifically
about that flight.
But I fly a lot.
Is that true on just
about every flight,
that there is somebody who
has never flown in their life,
and they've got no idea what it
means to fly on a regional jet?
Am I the only one?
And so I insert that in.
That's an embellishment.
But the story is true.
That happened to me.
So it has to be true, and
yes, you can embellish it.
How long should a story be?
As long as it takes
to be powerful.
I told you two stories today.
The airport story was
about nine minutes long.
The pill in the
peanut butter story
was about four minutes long.
Pill in the peanut butter story
doesn't need to be much longer.
That's the right amount
of time to do that.
The airport story is a much
bigger theatrical story.
That's what it takes to do that.
Here's a guideline.
Three to six minutes.
But if you think a 30
second vignette is a story,
you are wrong.
It's a vignette.
It's really not that engaging.
It's interesting.
But it's not engaging.
It's not compelling.
You need to look at
your presentation
in terms of what
presentation have
I got that I just have to win.
I have to have a
story that just rocks.
It has to nail it.
I mean, it's just got to
compel people to action.
I have to get them
to change their mind.
I have to get them to
change their perspective.
I have to move them.
Well, if you want to
move them, then you
need to be moving them with
energy and passion and power
and personality and an
incredibly crafted story,
a story theater story.
Now, the last one is
how do you determine
the point of your story?
You don't stick a point
on this just generic,
I want to tell a
story about this,
and I'm going to stick
this point on this story.
You have to look at what did
you do to overcome the obstacle.
When you were in that situation
and that obstacle, that crisis,
that challenge occurred,
what was your process?
So I want you to take
a look at the story
that you've got in
your mind right now,
and I want you to go
back and visualize,
when that thing
happened, what was
the first thing that happened?
The second thing that happened?
Was there a thought?
Was there emotion?
Was there an action?
And then what did I do?
And then what did I think?
And then what did I feel?
And then what did I do?
And literally create a
sequence in your mind
of every thought, every
action, and every reaction.
And sequence that
all out, and then
look in terms of what
did I do for the lesson.
Now, when I was at the curb
and the shuttle bus went away,
my first thought was,
I'm going to be late.
And my second thought
was, oh no you're not.
You have a keynote to give.
Come on, find something.
Look around.
Find something.
So I started to look around,
and I started to look around,
and I looked, and
there was a limo.
And because my mind
said shuttle bus,
I hadn't even seen
that there was
a limo sitting in front of me.
Look for the limo.
So it took me awhile to work
through that process of what
did I do at the curb.
But when I got to the place
where I finally look around
for-- look for the limo.
Good language.
Look for the limo.
That's really cool.
And then you know
the embellishment?
I gave the words look for
the limo to the limo driver.
I created a Yoda.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DOUG STEVENSON: That's good.
Because when you
create a Yoda, and you
give the profound language to
somebody like him, and he says,
don't look for the shuttle, man.
Look for the limo.
Then you can react to it.
You could do what I call
a self-reflective echo.
Look for the limo.
You guys aren't
even knowing, I'm
doing like 27
techniques in here.
And they all work really well
because they're subliminal
and they're cool and they're
a little bit of story theater.
Is this fun or what?
Oh my gosh, I'm keeping
you awake during lunch.
The last one is there are
different kinds of stories
for different situations.
I'm going to just give you nine
different types of stories.
There's a crucible
story, a severe test.
There's an imbroglio
story, a comedy of errors.
There's a profile story,
a story about Larry Page
and Sergey Brin.
It's a profile story.
There is a vignette, which is a
short little interesting thing.
Not well developed.
There's a credibility story.
That's a story that
you use to sell
yourself, your credibility, in a
job interview or with a client.
The client wondering,
well who the heck are you
and what have you ever done
and why should I trust you?
There's a credibility
story for that.
It's a sales story.
There's a pattern
story where you've
learned a lesson over
a period of years.
There's an instructional
story that's
much more technical,
much more instructional.
It's got the imagery
and the emotion,
but it's much more
of a technical story.
And then finally,
there's a Minerva story.
Ancient wisdom.
A Sufi story.
A Native American story.
Any kind of a folk story.
So these are the different
kinds of stories.
Now on the last
page, page six, I'm
just going to give
you some information.
You could just look
at it at your leisure.
The nine steps of story
structure and the phrase
that pays, how you
arrive at those.
But here's what I want
you to be aware of.
If you are listening
to this on the feed,
or if you're watching this on
the Google channel on YouTube,
or if any of you would
like a copy of this handout
for someone else, or you
would like the article called
"The Nine Steps of Story
Structure" article,
here's what you do.
Send an email to me,
doug@dougstevenson.com.
So D-O-U-G at
D-O-U-G-S-T-E-V-E-N-S-O-N dot
com.
And in the subject line,
just write Google handout.
And I will email a PDF
of this handout to you,
along with an article on the
nine steps of story structure
that fleshes it out
a little bit more.
So today has been an
absolute joy and a pleasure
to be on the Google
campus with you
here in Mountain
View, California.
It's a lovely day.
Go on out and story on.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]